at what age did you become famous I
started working in New York as a
stand-up comedian when I was 10 and I
got my first job which was a show called
The Amanda Show which was like sketch
comedy for kids Amanda Bynes like crazy
brilliant oh wow Beyond her years Talent
still is I was 13 and that moved me out
to California and in that day and age if
you were remotely funny you were on one
kid's show you were probably gonna get a
show with your name in it too and Keenan
and Cal had been off for a couple years
they needed another buddy comedy and
here comes Drake and Josh it blows my
mind that a 10 year old is going on
stage to be funny right what kind of
what kind of jokes does a 10 year old
have you know what's the deal with uh
through Roma